you know what really grinds my gears
when the media says so-and-so faces up
to 110 billion years in prison and while
that's theoretically possible it's never
right and here Trump faces real jail
time for what he's accused of how much
exactly well luckily scowl knows exactly
how much jail time Trump would get if
he's convicted thanks Devin you know it
wasn't until this moment that I actually
started suspecting that I died and went
to hell doing a deep dive into the
federal sentencing guidelines from
Donald Trump's case I mean I think Dante
mentioned that as happening somewhere on
the lower levels Federal sentencing a
rational predictable and fair process
that would be impossible to thwart by a
narcissistic man child who runs a major
political party as a cult of personality
unless you've been living under a rock
you've heard that Donald Trump was
indicted in the southern district of
Florida for 36 counts relating to the
willful retention of classified
documents as well as a scheme to
obstruct the investigation into that
retention we've done at least one video
on this channel but here's the Cliff's
Notes of what's alleged when he left
office on January 20th 2021 Donald Trump
caused a bunch of boxes filled with
classified National Defense information
to be moved to his Mar-A-Lago club in
Palm Beach Florida according to the
indictment Trump had the boxes stored in
unsecured locations and even showed some
of those materials to visitors possibly
including Kid Rock not joking beginning
in May 2021 the National Archives and
Records Administration repeatedly
demanded that Trump turn over certain
records that he had kept after his
presidency Trump didn't comply so
ultimately on March 30th 2022 the FBI
opened a criminal investigation into the
unlawful retention of classified
documents at Mar-A-Lago and on May 11th
of 2022 a Federal grand jury issued a
subpoena to Trump requiring the
production of all documents with
classification markings
Trump caused some documents to be
produced on June 3rd 2022 along with a
certification from one of his attorneys
Trump attorney number three according to
the indictment that all documents had
been produced well as it turns out that
certification was false the FBI got its
hands on surveillance footage showing
Trump's valet Walt nauda as well as
another employee moving boxes around
Mar-A-Lago in advance of June 3rd to
hide certain documents
so on August 8 2022 the FBI executed a
search warrant on Mar-A-Lago and found
the remaining documents
the indictment contains 37 separate
charges although only 36 relate to Trump
counts 1-31 charged Trump with willfully
retaining National Defense information
in violation of 18 USC 793 e which is
the Espionage Act counts 1-21 relate to
documents that were obtained during that
August 8th search warrant while counts
22 to 31 relate to documents that were
produced by Trump's attorney on June 3rd
comes 32-36
are basically a bunch of different ways
of charging obstruction of justice for
hiding the documents that were recovered
on August 8th
so here's the question
what's Trump looking at if you were to
take this case to trial and be found
guilty of all counts counts 1-36
what kind of sentence would he receive
what's at stake here now you'll remember
in our George Santos video I took a
quick little dive into the federal
sentencing guidelines now we're going to
take it to 11. these gone to 11. we are
going to nerd out and I'm not even going
to apologize for it this is going to be
fun but I'm also going to tell you this
this is the only time we're doing it in
any future video where we're going to
talk about the federal sentencing
guidelines we're just going to put up a
little thumbnail and Link you back to
this one I'm just not doing this twice
in 1984 the United States Congress
overwhelmingly passed the sentencing
Reform Act the sensing Reform Act did a
couple different things including
eliminating Federal parole but most
importantly for our purposes it
established the United States sentencing
commission that commission was tasked
with creating the sentencing guidelines
the basic policy behind the sentencing
guidelines was to establish a fair and
effective sentencing system there were
three fundamental goals in the new
sentencing scheme
first honesty and sentencing second
reasonable uniformity and three
proportionality
honesty and sentencing was easy to
achieve with the elimination of federal
parole a person sentenced to prison
serves that sentence minus maybe 15 for
good behavior reasonable uniformity and
proportionality however are a little bit
more difficult and they're sometimes in
tension with one another the sentencing
guidelines can't take into account every
single detail and Wrinkle in every
single case so in addition to creating a
framework for treating similarly
situated defendants similarly the
guidelines allowed for departures from
the guidelines under certain
circumstances in other words the
guidelines maintained a limited amount
of discretion for judges to give
leniency or impose harsher sentences at
the time it was created the idea was
that the sentencing guidelines would be
binding on federal judges but the
Supreme Court put a pin in that on
separation of powers grounds the Supreme
Court said that federal judges could be
forced to consider the sentencing
guidelines and appellate course could
presume those sentences were reasonable
but judges could not be bound by them
entirely the sensing guidelines rely on
something called the sentencing table
the vertical axis tracks the seriousness
of the offense an offense level of one
results in a much lower sentence than an
offense level of 28. the horizontal axis
tracks the criminal history of the
defendant the greater the criminal
history the greater the sentence
so defendant with no criminal history
who commits a crime with an offense
level of 17 has a guidelines range of 24
to 30 months in prison
if only it were that simple
each crime has a base offense level and
then potentially a bunch of adjustments
up or down from that base offense level
it gets even more complicated when the
defendant is convicted of multiple
crimes
and we will get there in any given
Federal Criminal Case there are three
steps the district court judge has to
follow to sentence the defendant first
correctly calculate the applicable
guidelines range any sentence within the
guidelines range so long as the
guidelines were applied correctly which
is a big assumption and subject to much
litigation can be presumed to be
reasonable
second consult the grounds for departure
provided in the policy statements of the
sentencing guidelines and third apply
the factors contained in 18 USC section
3553 a so what are those factors
I mean they're pretty generic look at
the nature and circumstances of the
crime and the characteristics of the
defendant consider how the sentence will
impose a just punishment deter other
criminal conduct protect the public and
potentially reform the defendant
and look at how defendants with similar
records in similar cases were sentenced
to avoid unwarranted disparities between
defendants
when appellate courts review a Federal
Criminal sentence they have their own
little two-step dance to do the first
step is to ensure that the district
court committed no significant
procedural error such as improperly
calculating the guidelines range the
second step is to consider the
substantive reasonableness of the
sentence itself taking into account the
totality of the circumstances including
the extent of any variance from the
guidelines range the Appellate Court
considers the substantive reasonableness
of the sentence itself under an abusive
discretion standard which is pretty
deferential to the district court judge
okay with all that in mind let's look at
Trump's indictment we're going to start
with a willful retention counts counts
one through 31. what are the base
offense levels of those counts
well the sentencing guidelines actually
don't make this super easy probably
because while this crime does come up
it's not as common as say robbery there
are two sections of the guidelines that
seem like they could apply 2m 3.2 and 2m
3.3 I'm just going to call those
sections two and three just to make
things easy plenty of commentators have
used section two probably because it's
title in the guidelines is gathering
National Defense information while
section 3's title refers to transmitting
and disclosing well so it seems obvious
right there's also probably some
motivated reasoning because section 2
has a higher base offense level 35 for
top secret information and 30 otherwise
that's in contrast to section three
where it's 29 for top secret information
and 24 otherwise
sadly for those commentators they're
probably wrong and United States V
Aquino the third circuit hit this issue
squarely on the nose and held that
willful retention exactly what Trump is
accused of doing gets the Lesser
guidelines range in section three
incidentally the second circuit agreed
with the third circuit the next year in
United States V Mulkey
and while neither of these decisions
binds the southern district of Florida
which is in the 11th circuit the third
circuit's analysis in Aquino is pretty
persuasive so let's just work under that
framework Section 3 applies for the
willful retention counts then for every
count alleging the retention of top
secret information the base offense
level is 29 and for each other count
alleging something not top secret the
base offense level is 24. the next thing
we do is look at some adjustments there
are three adjustments that seem like
they could probably apply here the first
adjustment is for Trump's role as
organizer or leader of the alleged
criminal activity there is no doubt that
he was the leader the decision maker
when it came to the retention of the
classified documents as such he gets a
two-point increase from the base offense
level now if the criminal activity
involved five or more participants or
was otherwise extensive the court can
add another two points to the base
offense level I'm not convinced that we
have it here I've seen some other
commentators do it but I'm not going to
based on the indictment we could have
five participants while NADA employee
number two and attorneys one through
three the problem is that a participant
is defined as someone also criminally
responsible for the offense
and it's not entirely clear just how
criminally responsible employee 2 and
attorneys one through three really are
nor is extensive defined so I think it's
safer just to give Trump a two-point
increase for a general leadership role
and believe me it's not going to make
that much of a difference later on the
second adjustment is for abuse of a
position of trust Trump can get another
two-point increase if he abused a
position of public or private trust in a
manner that significantly facilitated
the commission or concealment of the
offense
this is a bit of a no-brainer and it's
frequently applied in these kinds of
cases after all virtually all people
charged with willfully retaining
National Defense information had a right
to access that National Defense
information at some point they had
clearance and need to know which
arguably really only comes from a
position of public Trust
for former president trump it seems even
more obvious he had access to those
documents by virtue of his role as
president which significantly
facilitated the commission of the crimes
alleged
this was not just extreme carelessness
with classified material
which is still totally disqualifying
this is calculated deliberate
premeditated misconduct followed by a
cover-up that included false statements
and lies to Congress the media and the
American people the third and final
adjustment is for obstruction of justice
that's another two-point increase to the
base offense level
now you may think we're getting ahead of
ourselves we're talking about willful
retention counts not the obstruction of
justice counts
but the sentencing guidelines often
contain adjustments or cross-references
like this and a big part of it is in the
philosophy of the sentencing guidelines
we'll see that clearly later on when
we're talking about grouping but suffice
it to say the obstruction of justice
adjustment counts so what are we left
with well for each of the counts
alleging willful retention of top secret
information we have an adjusted Defense
level of 35. that's the base offense
level of 29 plus 2 for the leadership
rule plus two for the abuse of public
trust and plus two for obstruction
for each count alleging willful
retention of other than top secret
information we have an adjusted offense
level of 30. that's a base offense level
of 24 plus 2 for the leadership role
plus two for the abuse of public trust
and plus two for obstruction
if we assume that Trump has no criminal
history at the time of sentencing and
adjust the defense level of 35 carries a
presumptive 168 to 210 months in prison
or about 14 to 17 and a half years oh
but we are not done yet
what about the rest of the charges in
the indictment even with different names
and charges counts 32-36 are all going
to be analyzed under the same section of
the guidelines to X 3.1
I am not going to walk us through the
details on these but I'll just say that
I think it's likely that for counts
32-36 each will have an adjusted Defense
level of 27. that's a base offense level
of 23 plus two for the leadership role
and plus two for the abuse of public
trust you don't get the adjustment for
obstruction of justice because that's
the crime
with no criminal history each of counts
32-36 has a guidelines range of 70 to 87
months or about six to seven years in
prison if we assume that Trump has no
criminal history at the time of
sentencing and adjust the defense level
of 35 carries a presumptive 168 to 210
months in prison or about 14 to 17 and a
half years
for the adjusted Defense level of 30 we
have 97 to 121 months so up to about 10
years oh but we are not done yet okay
wow so we're talking 31 counts of
willful retention where we're looking at
8 to 10 or 14 to 17 and a half years in
prison and another five counts where he
could get six to seven years that means
Trump's going to get like 500 years in
prison right no
just just know
now we have to do a little something the
guidelines calls grouping the
fundamental philosophical idea behind
grouping is this
a defendant who injures 10 people during
a fight May warrant more punishment than
if he injures one but his conduct is not
necessarily warrant 10 times the
punishment grouping is also meant as a
check on prosecutors prosecutor may be
able to charge a defendant under 10
different statutes for a single criminal
act but that doesn't mean that the
defendant should get 10 times the
sentence
there are four ways of grouping closely
related counts but only three are
potentially relevant to Trump's case
a when counts involve the same victim
and the same act or transaction B when
counts involve the same victim and two
or more Acts or transactions connected
by a common criminal objective or
constituting part of a common scheme or
plan
or C when one of the counts embodies
conduct that is treated as a specific
offense characteristic in or other
adjustment to the guideline applicable
to another of the counts so right off
the bat we're going to make three kind
of provisional groups counts one through
21 get grouped together because they
basically involve the same conduct over
the same date range January 20th of 2021
through August 8th of 2022. you just
have separate counts based on separate
documents the counts 22-31 get grouped
together for the same reason although
the date range is different January 20th
of 2021 through June 3rd of 2022 so
let's think back why do we have the
different date ranges it's because the
documents encounts 22 through 31 were
turned over to the FBI on June 3rd 2022
along with that false certification
signed by Trump attorney three
it was only later that the FBI obtained
surveillance video showing the movement
of boxes in Mar-A-Lago which resulted in
the August 8th search warrant and it was
through that search warrant that the FBI
found the documents for counts 1 through
21.
so should all those willful retention
counts be grouped together after all
there's a single victim the federal
government and wasn't the willful
retention of the National Defense
information
connected by a common criminal objective
or was there a common scheme or plan I
get that argument I do
but the idea behind that kind of
grouping is that there's a single
composite harm from the criminal scheme
so think about a different example if a
defendant is convicted of three counts
of mail fraud for mailings that happen
on three separate days those three
counts can be grouped together to
represent the composite harm of the
overall mail fraud scheme but in Trump's
case the federal government might be
able to point to a separate and distinct
harm between counts 1-21 on one hand and
counts 22-31 on the other
after all the FBI had to go and execute
a search warrant for the former
president's Club a pretty remarkable
event in our nation's history moreover
the entire obstruction of justice scheme
really related to those documents the
ones that were ultimately obtained by
the search warrant not the ones turned
over on June 3rd in fact arguably the
documents turned over on June 3rd are
part and parcel of that obstruction of
justice scheme since they were intended
to convince the federal government that
all the documents had been turned over
so for this video we're going to keep
counts 1 through 21 and counts 22-31 as
separate groups but spoiler alert it
doesn't make a huge difference in the
end we are however going to group counts
1 through 21 with counts 32-36 the
obstruction of justice counts why well
for one because we've already used the
obstruction of justice adjustment to the
base offense levels for those counts we
added two points to counts 1-21 for the
obstruction of justice
and this kind of grouping is designed to
avoid double counting again it's a sort
of check on charging Decisions by
prosecutors and overly aggressive judges
so in the end we're left with two groups
counts one through 21 and 32-36
constitute the first group
counts 22-31 constitute the second group
all right
we are almost at the end of this
interminable process
we're going to take the most serious
adjusted Defense level from the first
group and a bunch of them share it it's
35. for willful retention of top secret
information and all that that second
group does is allow us to add two points
to the 35 for a grand total combined
Defense level of 37. I'll say that again
the combined Defense level of 37 covers
the entire indictment all the charges so
with no criminal history for the entire
indictment Trump gets a final guidelines
range of 210 to 262 months in prison or
about 17 and a half to 22 years
okay that was fun wasn't it I mean I was
told there would be no math but here we
are it was my understanding that there
would be no math so that's it right if
Donald J Trump were convicted of all
charges in the indictment after trial
he'd go to prison for 17 and a half to
22 years in prison ah no nope that would
be too easy we're lawyers and if it were
easy you wouldn't need us and we need
job security
so first of all any violation of 18 USC
793e the willful retention statute from
the Espionage Act has a maximum
punishment of 10 years in prison so if a
judge thinks that the total guidelines
range is appropriate 17 and a half to 22
years the judge is going to have to run
some counts consecutively to get there
and they have that Authority the judge
has two more things to consider
first departures
remember the sentencing guidelines
themselves recognize that a departure
from the guidelines range might be
appropriate under certain circumstances
a departure can go upward to more prison
time or downward to less including to
probation the guidelines include
considerations unique to the defendant
like their age education and Vocational
skills employment record Family Ties and
responsibilities and more they also
include considerations about the crimes
themselves such as whether the victim
suffered significant physical injury or
whether there was a significant
disruption in governmental function or
even the victim's conduct and again so
much more second and perhaps more
importantly remember that the guidelines
themselves are just advisory at the end
of this entire process the judge
considers the factors outlined in 18 USC
3553-a which again basically tells the
judge to look at the totality of the
circumstances and to avoid any sort of
unwarranted sentencing disparities
between defendants with similar Records
who committed similar crimes so what's a
judge to do this indictment presents
circumstances that really have never
been seen before
while plenty of people have gone to
prison for long periods of time for
willful retention of National Defense
information none of those people are a
former president not to mention one who
is actively campaigning for the
presidency now whether that's something
that the sentencing judge should even
take into consideration or what weight
they should give it is arguable no
matter what though the sensing judge
would have to balance some pretty unique
considerations in obtaining a just
outcome those unique considerations
might blow up any attempt to compare
Trump's sentence with others who
committed similar conduct and so in the
end it's going to be up to the judge as
the saying goes a good lawyer knows the
law but a great lawyer knows the judge
you could have a district court judge
say uh rileen Shannon who could laugh at
the guidelines range and depart to
probation but you could also have a
judge who has a very different opinion
and the nice thing about the sensing
guidelines is it could give that kind of
a judge cover we don't like to consider
judges as Political Animals but they are
to a certain extent and if a judge who's
so inclined is able to point to the
sentencing guidelines and say look
that's what it tells me to do it gives
them a little bit of cover in imposing
what some people might consider a harsh
sentence now the government like the
defendant can appeal a sentence but as
long as the judge followed all the
procedures and articulated a reasonable
basis for perhaps a departure to
probation
an appellate court might not find that
it was an abuse of discretion all that's
to say that nothing is written in stone
here
all we know is that a very long prison
term 17 and a half to 22 years would
probably be reasonable and appropriate
under the guidelines
but we have no idea how a judge in this
case might actually sentence Donald
Trump assuming that Donald Trump is
found guilty after trial on all of these
charges whoever the sentencing judge is
is going to have a very hard decision to
make of course when and if judge Cannon
issues that order she's going to have to
write it down clearly and concisely
which she can do with today's sponsor
grammarly now grammarly go accelerates
your writing process by generating and
modifying text instantly on demand
you'll be writing responsive thoughtful
emails and posts faster than ever it's a
huge productivity boost and unlike other
AI tools grammarly go tailors its output
to your unique context it picks up on
key details and incorporates them into
what you're writing I can set my voice
to be casual and empathetic for example
if I'm running to friends or I can set
it to be more direct if I'm writing to
enemies like opposing counsel and of
course this is grammarly so it fixes
poor writing in the first place not that
you know I would ever do that and it can
give prompts to make something shorter
sharper and more exciting now as a
content creator I have to do a lot of
scripting writing and with grammarly
ghost features I can rewrite my scripts
to be more engaging instantly and as a
lawyer I had to do a lot of writing and
translating legal jargon into something
more readable and grammarly goes rewrite
feature helps me communicate more
clearly the way that I want I just have
to make sure that I do all the legal
research myself but you can even use it
for ideation to get ideas about what you
want to write about in the first place
you'll be amazed at what you can do with
grammarly go so if you want to give it a
try you can get 20 off by going to the
link that's on screen right now or down
in the description again to be more
productive than ever and get 20 off of
grammarly go just click on the link
below and after that click on this link
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court